hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today's lesson is about
post-transcriptional modification of
mRNA so first let's talk about where
this process happens it happens in
eukaryotic cells remember that there are
two major cell types that all life in
the world can it is one or the other
there are eukaryotes and prokaryotes and
so today we're talking about eukaryotes
which are the animal cell and plant
cells and fungal cells and algal cells
and not bacteria or archaea cells so
post-transcriptional modifications mrna
happened in eukaryotes so we know about
the processes of transcription and
translation remember that transcription
is where the mRNA is made from a DNA
template and translation is where that
mRNA is taken to a ribosome where it is
then translated into protein so we're
going to use to thinking that
transcription makes mRNA that's not
quite the right way to say that absolute
transcription they pre mRNA and again
this is just in eukaryotic cells and
prokaryotic cells transcription make
them RNA so eukaryotic cells transfer to
make pre mRNA that then must be
processed post transcriptionally meaning
after transcription into mature RNA and
so what kind of processes are happening
during that modification process and s31
instead of five prime cap de jamón so a
five prime cap is especially altered
nucleotides that is added to the 5 prime
end or the starting end of the mRNA
transcript also at the at the other end
of the transcript to the other
and the by prime cap there is a three
prime poly a tail and so what's the
purpose of adding using we're adding the
specialized cap in this specialized tail
the poly a tail is so named because it
is made up of several adenine and
nucleotides so aadmi of the a poly is
because there are many a's in a row and
ELISA point well they get added to
protect the transcript and that is that
and you carry on it cytoplasm there are
factors essential enzyme known as rnases
that will chew up a single-stranded RNA
well that will recognize single-stranded
RNA like mRNA as this bad foreign thing
that needs to be eat grated and this is
an evolutionary and answer to buy a roll
infection many viruses use
single-stranded RNA as their genetic
material so if they affect the cell and
there's lots of viral RNA in the cell
and the cell tries to degrade it so the
same enzymes can actually hurt the mRNA
transcript into the cell add to five
friend cat a three time poly a tail to
either end of the transcript in order to
protect it from these enzymes that would
otherwise degraded now there's a third
process it's important with
post-transcriptional modification and
that is called splicing so what happens
is that part of the pre mRNA transcript
gets spliced out the parts that get
spliced out our non-coding parts and
they don't code for protein and they are
called introns so entrance get spliced
acts the parts that are maintained
they're kept in that final mature mRNA
transcript are called exons
and exons are the coding regions of the
NRA transcripts that are kept because
they actually code for protein and so
here you can see that we have a pre mRNA
transcript the parts in white are the
introns the parts in black are the exons
and after splicing you get all of the
exons joints together and the introns is
in removed let's talk a minute about the
name and tron and the name exon because
there's a way to help you remember which
one of these lifestyles and which one is
being kept and that is it end time takes
its name from intervening sequences so
there the sequences that are intervening
or that are in between the exons that
are speak act exons get their name from
expressed element so that the X and
epsilon and the ES and express meaning
if the exons are the parts of the
transcript that are later going to be
actually expressed in protein and that's
because they are doing together they are
kept in the final mRNA transect that
then goes on to be translated on a
ribosome so now let's talk about a few
other important points with
post-transcriptional modification and as
it's each step whether it is the five
prime cap or the suite plan called the a
tail or the splicing procedures these
are complex processes that involve the
activity of multiple enzymes so just as
an example within the five prime cap
being procedure that adds that
specialized nucleotides to the front end
of the mRNA to protect it there are at
least three major enzymes involved and
those are phosphatase iguana
self-transformation
and a methyl transferase they each have
different names because they have
different functions that are our part
for that five prime capping procedure if
you're interested in learning more about
enzymes in general how they work the
factors that affect them and please see
my video on introduction
and I'm now eukaryotic transcripts also
tend to only have one per transcript
this is called mono subsonic and so each
transcript each Priya learning this may
generally only contain the information
for one gene that's going to go on to
code for one protein except in the cases
of alternative splicing which I also
have a video on that you can see now
these modifications on JD's
modifications are talking about the five
prime cap the street cred poly a tail
and splicing they do not occur in
prokaryotes at all they don't occur in
prokaryotes because transcription and
translation in prokaryotes which are
bacteria and our ESL these processes are
coupled in prokaryotes couples meaning
that they're actually happening at the
same time and so they're not a space and
time for these kinds of modifications to
occur if you're interested in learning
more about coupled transcription and
translation of prokaryotes and please
see my video on that topic and thank you
for watching today this is the end of
the lesson and I hope you will watch
some of my other lessons on my biology
professors channel thanks for watching
bye